n'est on passe maintenant notre
décryptage en fort knox
soir anthony bon ordre et bonsoir à tous
alors qu emmanuel macron était hier à
moscou est aujourd'hui à kiev pour
aboutir à une désescalade en ukraine
depuis plusieurs semaines les
spéculations sur l'imminence d'une
invasion russe vont bon train mais
d'après encore ce soir avec deux vidéos
tik tok décortiqué par o2 j'avais arthur
bavasse des observateurs de france 24 on
va la regarder ensemble audrey cette
vidéo des militaires et qui court qui
tirent et qui s'abritent dans des
maisons en ruines on entend des coups de
feu cette vidéo elle a été proposée en
espagnol depuis le 23 janvier environ et
cumule plus de
37000 duel porte on voit le logo vert
devrait s'attirer des chaînes d'info en
continu financé par le kremlin et retour
à cette publication à tik tok il y à
cette légende en espagnol qui nous dit
l'armée russe détruits et envahit une
petite ville d'ukraine qu'en est il
réellement eh bien c'est la réponse est
bien d'une simple recherche youtube on
entre les mots clés rt je vous le disais
pour russia today et militaires s arrose
hausse pour russe militaire russe en
espagnol on tombe sur différentes
occurrences et on retrouve la vidéo ici
elle et elle date de
2019 en l'occurrence du 5 mars 2019 ont
atterri sur la chaîne youtube en
espagnol de russia today on n'est pas en
ukraine non on est en syrie il s'agit
d'instructeurs militaires russes c'est
vrai entraînant des membres de fors des
forces de l'armée arabe syrienne à alep
et on peut d'ailleurs à plusieurs
reprises repéré le l'écusson de déforcer
l'arabisation music effectivement sur
l'uniforme alors toujours sur tic toc
une seconde vidéo fait état d'un nouvel
arsenal nucléaire russe res on adore
cette vidéo on la découvre à nouveau
ensemble un c est celle ci plus de
700000 vu depuis une semaine on y voit
vladimir poutine face à un public
plusieurs engins militaires on les
découvre dans à l'écran qui sont
présentés et la légende de dire le
nouveau jouet nucléaire de poutine
légende évidemment trompeuse comme
souvent c'est une recherche d'image
inversée en l'occurrence dans
dans le moteur de recherche russe yandex
ça nous met la puce à l'oreille cette
recherche d'image l'inversé parce que
lorsque vous faites une capture d'écran
comme ici vous obtenez plusieurs
occurrences et en l'occurrence justement
l'une des délires d'art l'un des
résultats c'est la chaîne youtube
italienne d'une émission d'actualité à
tg 2000 c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que
vous avez ici le logo qui apparaissait
sur la vidéo virale et lorsqu'on
effectue une recherche complémentaire
avec elle les dates on tombe sur des
articles dont ceux de france 24 qui
évoque ce discours de vladimir poutine
en étant mars 2018 le premier exactement
un discours devant des députés et des
sénateurs c'est vrai il présente à
l'époque son arsenal nucléaire pour je
cite mettre en garde ses agresseurs
potentiels mais cette vidéo comme
l'autre d'ailleurs vous l'avez bien
compris n'ont rien à voir avec le cren
et les hot dogs concernant vladimir
poutine ont la vie dure oui hier qu on
se souvient de la rencontre entre
vladimir poutine emmanuel macron qui a
donné lieu à deux nombreux détournements
humoristiques j'ai pas pu m'en en
empêcher il ya à la taille de la table
on sait qu'il va faire beaucoup parler
d'elle notamment cet internaute qui nous
disent toutes les options sont sur la
table et bien il y en a beaucoup alors
là évidemment pas de quoi crier à la fox
puisque les trucages sont évidents mais
c'est vrai que c'est pas toujours le cas
et justement à la faveur de ce qui se
passe à la frontière avec l'ukraine une
vidéo est revenu sur le devant de la
scène depuis fin janvier c'est celle ci
fin janvier qu'est ce qui se passe on se
souvient emmanuel macron qui a assuré
qu'en cas d'agression aux russes la
riposte sera là et le coût très élevé
cette vidéo aux russes cette vidéo non
pas aux russes mais cette vidéo qui a
circulé est censée montrer le président
russe qui se nomme il y a quelques
années puisqu'on voit en gala merkel et
donald trump emmanuel macron refusant de
lui serrer la main du petit lait dont
pour ses détracteurs un maquereau faible
fasse un maître du kremlin fort comment
s'imposer quand on a subi une telle
humiliation sauf que comme non décrypté
les observe deux observateurs de france
24 il ya quelques mois avec d'autres
exemples est bien là cette séquence a
été volontairement tronquée voici
l'original on est en 2000 8 l'occasion
de la dune du centenaire pardon de
l'armistice de 1918 évidemment à paris à
l'arc de triomphe il ya bien eu poignée
de main avec emmanuel macron et on finit
en musique oui on va regarder une vidéo
ensemble beaucoup de vidéos ce soir on
va surtout écouter
c'est vous apparemment monneret note
seven nation army des white stripes
2003 interprété ici au piano par
vladimir poutine dans cette vidéo qui a
ressurgi ces derniers jours la
définition même du frisson selon
certains twittos au regard du contexte
on rappelle les premières paroles je les
combats très tous une armée de cette
nation ne pourrais pas me retenir toute
ressemblance avec une situation une
allusion à une quelconque alliance
atlantique est évidemment fortuite ces
images qui porte le logo de lagence
horus l' agence de presse russe pique
nique se sont pourtant vu ajouter de la
musique évidemment et ce détournement il
existait déjà à l'époque il ya quatre
ans puisque cette vidéo elle date de
2017 juste avant une rencontre avec le
président chinois xi jingping on est à
pékin on va écouter l'original de ce
petit interlude un proviseur
voilà ça n'a rien à voir avec des white
sox on notera que
vladimir poutine et pacy virtuose en
piano que ça si je puis me permettre
[Musique]
et pendant entendu un petit accident m
je crois avoir cassé mon oreillette je
vais me faire taper sur les doigts merci
beaucoup anthony saint léger à l'est on
referme cette demi heure d'information
avec vous et on se retrouve nous dans
quelques instants pour un nouveau
journal
[Musique]